hi there steve coffin here today i want
to talk about
habits habits of a lazy language learner
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications yeah
i want to talk about
my language learning style now and what
i would call
being a lazy language learner which
doesn't necessarily mean that you aren't
being a successful language learner it
just means that you're being
lazy the way i'm being lazy and so there
are seven habits i think that we need to
acquire
if we're going to be effective
successful lazy
language learners the first is to set
low
goals okay so on my 90-day challenge
i've set my goal for creating links at
13
for arabic and 13 for persian
and there was a time when i was trying
to do a hundred new links
in arabic persian and turkish
it was simply too much so i've changed
my style now i set low goals now
i regularly exceed these goals if i look
at my statistics
but the low goal just gets me going i
don't see
you know that i don't feel any great
burden or obligation i just get started
and once i'm launched
i'll generally you know exceed my goals
but my first habit therefore is to set
low goals now i have a bit of a cheat
sheet here so i'm gonna
make sure i don't forget the second
thing is
don't compete with others i'm not
competing with other people
uh in my challenge i'm not comparing
myself to others
some people are going faster i see that
i'm ranked 1572 on my streak
that's fine some people are going to
pronounce better some people are going
to learn
faster slower whatever it doesn't matter
i'm learning it for myself
so i'm not competing that reduces the
stress level
anything that reduces the stress level
makes learning more enjoyable
makes learning more effective the
next thing is to be a lazy language
learner you got to go with the flow
do things that you want to do for
example
i'm on my arabic and persian challenge
but lo and behold my wife starts
watching a danish
series on netflix and i love listening
to danish and there's lots of words i
don't understand
so i say i'm gonna do a bit of danish so
i spend a day out of my week or more
listening to the mini stories in danish
hence christian anderson stories in
danish
saving a bunch of danish words so that i
have some sense
of some of these words that i hear in
this uh
tv series called the sea view hotel that
i don't understand and now i understand
it a lot better
similarly i started watching an egyptian
movie
for fun so follow your wishes and i
guess that ties into the
fourth habit of a lazy language learning
learner
and that is treat language learning as a
form of entertainment
okay and include entertainment so
obviously when i watch the danish series
i understand a lot of it and
by doing a little work on link i
understand a lot more
uh with the movies the egyptian movies
i'm speaking with my tutor or at least
we're going over the mini stories in
egyptian arabic which is different from
standard arabic
and my hope is that i'll understand
egyptian movies better
but watching an egyptian movie like the
movie i saw i think it's called
asma about a woman who has
aids in egypt i can enjoy the movie
i get this i hear the language i don't
really understand
much of it but it's a form of
entertainment it brings me into the
culture
language learning is it should be
entertainment
as well it shouldn't just be routine and
drills
and that kind of thing so allow yourself
to be entertained
um another thing about being a lazy
language learner is
i don't prepare for my sessions with my
tutor i don't prepare i just show up
with muhammad in egyptian arabic we just
open up a mini-story
i read a bit of it then we have some
questions on it
then we fade into a discussion of
something else in egyptian arabic
or in standard arabic more if we're
free conversations more standard arabic
than egyptian arabic
i struggle in both but i don't prepare
i just show up and and again whatever
exposure i get whatever i'm doing with
the language engaging with the language
during that hour with mohammed is all to
the good
so no need to get hung up about
preparing for the session
lazy language learner you just show up
one-on-one
and benefit
another important number six habit
of a lazy language learner is
when you're tired of doing something go
and do something else
introduce a lot of variety as long as
you're engaging with the language
you are achieving something so you're
tired of listening go do more reading
i sometimes feel i have to push myself a
little bit on the reading because i
think the reading is
is essential to acquiring vocabulary
obviously the listening is easier to do
while i'm doing other chores
but introduce movies and switch from one
language to another
[Music]
introduce variety a variety keeps it
interesting
you have less of a sense that you're
constantly sort of
pounding on the same door variety keeps
things
interesting enables you to be a lazy
language learner
and the final seventh habit of a lazy
language learner is
in a way don't measure yourself
don't compare yourself to what you did
before or where you would like to be or
what other people do
don't measure accept the fact
that the process is success
success is the fact that you are
engaging with the language
accept the fact that whatever you're
doing
as a lazy language learner it is helping
you it is helping the brain get used to
the language
some days you would like to be better
some days you're better than you thought
you
were sometimes you feel you've achieved
a lot over the last three months some
days you feel you're treading water
it doesn't matter the fact that you are
engaging with the language
is in itself success the fact that you
are
enjoying the process the fact that you
are continuing
to get involved with the language
listening reading watching
movies speaking whatever you're doing
that is
the that makes you successful because
you're continuing to do it
and if you continue to do it and if you
enjoy the process
even as a lazy language learner you will
reach your goals faster than in my
opinion
forcing yourself to do things that you
don't want to do
so there you have it the seven habits
of a lazy language learner which i
consider myself
to be although i do spend a lot of time
with my languages
bye for now